the exaltation of first meeting and
falling in love is I think everybody
would admit different than the feelings
that you might have after 25 years when
my wife watches this they say we'll be
talking about you know that very
romantic relationship has now evolved
into a marriage you know which like
everybody else's marriage is is complex
I'm assuming that most people their
first love and their teenage that that
unbelievable hole that opens up inside
them of longing and yearning pain and I
just know it's a has an unbreakable grip
but I can't tell you what it is just
life can't be without it I think that
most people believe that romantic love
dies after a certain number of weeks
months or years but my colleagues and I
have actually proved that wrong